NBA superstar LeBron James is teaming up
with other athletes to protect the
voting rights of black Americans in this
country James told the New York Times
the initiative is called more than a
vote it will help black Americans cast a
ballot in November and the athletes and
entertainers involved will use their
social media to call out voter
suppression it's a problem players on
the Los Angeles Clippers are also used
in social media to fight racism they
released this video on Monday Steve
Ballmer's and chairman of the team and
he joins us from Seattle to discuss so
many issues Steve Ballmer it's so good
to see you listen I know head coach Doc
Rivers is also involved in voter
initiatives this is an issue that
matters to both of you and the team so
would you take us inside the
conversations you guys are having with
the team about the moment we're living
in right now
good to see you yes yeah nice to see you
Gail thanks for having me no we've been
having a number of interesting
conversations diagnosed that down with
our Clippard players earlier this week
and it was interesting it was a chance
certainly for me to learn we've had
other team functions where I've also had
chances to learn but right now our
players are saying number one is they
want to be involved in educating the
white community on their life
experiences to help people be smarter
and be better able to help contribute to
eliminating the kind of racism that
makes their lives so very difficult the
other thing I'll add people are saying
because these are professional athletes
that that frankly everything is okay in
their lives and they say look you take a
uniform off your you know you're right
back in the mix with other black men you
know we all know that that's true I'm so
I'm curious you said an opportunity for
you to learn what did you learn Steve
that you didn't know before I think the
degree to which the smallest things in
life the smallest things in life can
cause a negative interact
for a black person in an interaction
with the police it's probably the thing
that I would underscore the most from
our our discussions and and talk you
know it you know we all know there's
disproportionality more
african-americans grow up in poverty
than it's true for for white people and
yet the the severity of that poverty
what it looks like is it's just
different if you just look at the
incarceration rate I know these from the
numbers for the poorest 20% of whites
versus the forests 20% of black people
21% of poor black males are in are
incarcerated that numbers only six
percent for example for white people now
that's number Steve talking but when you
hear our players tell their stories
about their families in their
neighborhoods that comes out yeah listen
I think it's great that you know this
information or making an effort to know
more about it I heard you say that you
were sad and you were angry after the
police murder of George Floyd we all
many people felt that way but I want to
know specifically from you why were you
sad and why were you angry it's hit
people in many different ways I was sad
because you know this family and this
man saw this most senseless of murders
and you I mean look that family was
going to be reliving that for all time
and so for the family mr. Floyd and of
course true mr. Floyd himself sadness
anger
look it is maddening to me that not more
has been done that people like me and
others haven't been able to contribute
more it is maddening to me I mean the
behavior of that officer oh my gosh
that's just not I mean I
it's not okay it's awful it's terrible
what am I supposed to do other than just
be enraged gale that's my reaction of
yeah any of other reactions that I've
had in others but those are primary yeah
you know and I you said Steve something
you said people like me and I want to
talk about people like you because you
have called other white CEOs out saying
that they need to stand up and take
action what's your message to them and
what's the reaction to your words about
that calling them to task so to speak
yeah I would say my number one message
to any white people at this stage is
there's an invitation that is clear now
and that call to action which is to look
to try to be an ally of these causes
that's that's the that's the issue how
do you be an ally of breaking down
racism and the legacies that come all
the way back from slavery what do you do
do you as a leader
are you galvanizing your people are you
donating resources are encouraging
volunteerism are you taking stands on
various legal initiatives and what is
the CEO doing on behalf of their company
and what are they doing - if not
encourage their employees to take a
specific action just educate people on
the issue let people know more yes let
them have the dialogue yes but then
point your employees to places in which
they can add they can make a difference
through their actions understand more
and then act in CEOs have a let's call
it a bully pulpit on which they can
deliver those message then their
employees not telling them exactly what
to do but showing them the range of
options
yeah and part of it part of that I think
the frustration is when we look at the
numbers Michael Jordan is the only black
owner in the NBA there's over thirty
thirty owners total I don't know the
exact number why do you think that that
is and what needs to be done to change
that well I'm going to correct you
one thing Gayle because it was one of
the things our players said to me the
other day that's important I may have
bought the equity in the LA Clippers but
I am the chairman of the LA Clippers
that is my title I was not I'm not I'm
not trying to but it was important to
our players that's why I thought I did
not understood
and when you when you when you think
about you know what does it take now
we're talking about wealth creation
I've been unbelievably blessed and I was
allowed to purchase a basketball team
great for me how do we give that kind of
economic upside to more African
Americans if you look at economic
mobility data it's not very good for for
African Americans and particularly for
african-american males you know the
chances you move up economically from
the bottom 20% to the top 20% it's you
know 11 percent that's not bad for
whites it's not great that same numbers
2% for blacks it's it's ridiculous so it
means investment in the communities it
means investment in early childhood
education it means working on the
schools it means improving the the
safety the environment and the the role
of the police in those environments it
means getting people into college you
have to make that whole pipeline of
investments at least that's what we've
been seeing or the that's what we've
been hearing seeing and that's where
we've been putting our resources you
know I can't say the long work if the
smart people are out there are telling
me these are the areas in which we can
help contribute financially to to
improve lives financial lives now the
word is that the NBA is going back to
back to the court people are very
excited about that can you just give us
a little detail about how that's going
to work
[Music]
there's there's a number of things that
they certainly have shared and yet I
know a league office is going to be
really focused on a few things number
one can we do this safely and there's
new health news coming all the time on
COBIT number two if we're going to do
this I know our players and our the
teams everybody the league everybody
wants to make sure it gets done in the
way that is super respectful to the
times were living in from a racial and
justice perspective and I know the
league and other players Association one
of the good things about the NBA is
there's a very tight partnership between
the legion teams and just that's being
worked through yeah I just heard Steve
that it's July 22nd but we had a story
on the news on this broadcast earlier
about the unrest in your city of Seattle
what's your take on what's happening
there and how it's being handled well
you know if you accept to me that this
would be a hotbed of activity I probably
would have said no see how tall is I
won't call it a sleepy town but this is
not yeah Los Angeles this is not my
hometown of Detroit so I guess I would
say first I'm happy to see the level of
activism that we've seen in Seattle I
don't know if the issue is that our
police force has been perhaps less well
trained because of less activity dealing
with these issues you know I was
watching the video of a confrontation
that's broke out and I think that's the
kind of thing that needs to be studied
as people now are talking for example
about police reform which could be a
very good an expert in but the Seattle
experience tells me I better learn about
it yeah it's an ongoing conversation we
thank you Steve Ballmer chairman
whatever your title you are still a
badass and a really good guy repeating
really doing good work I think people
should know that about you Thank You mr.
Ballmer for your time this morning